hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a German war drama film
called the tin drum spoilers ahead watch
out ants take care
[Music]
the movie is set in Poland right before
the start of the second world war in the
first scene a woman named Anna is
working in the field When a Stranger
Comes running towards her he introduces
himself as Joseph and frantically
explains that he needs help because some
cops are after him without asking much
Anna lets him hide under her skirt oh
the plan works and when the cops arrive
they find nothing and soon leave from
that day onwards Anna and Joseph become
Inseparable and eventually get married a
year passes by the two have given birth
to a daughter and the life seems to be
going well however one day the cops
eventually find Joseph and Surround him
near a lake they start firing at him so
left with no options Joseph jumps into
the water that was the last time anyone
saw him some believe that he drowned in
the water While others say that he fled
to America and became a successful
businessman others still say that he's a
merman now on the other hand with her
husband gone Anna has a hard time
raising her daughter she sells veg
tables and sometimes her body to
generate income the movie then cuts to
several years later Anna's daughter
Agnes has grown up to become a beautiful
woman several men want her but Agnes is
in a secret affair with her own cousin
Yan they often get intimate and have fun
however since they cannot get married
Agnes ties the knot with a German Chef
named Alfred a few months later she
becomes pregnant and gives birth to a
boy whom she names Oscar the strange
thing is that no one knows if he belongs
to her husband or her lover Oscar keeps
on crying perhaps because he didn't want
to come into this world but when Agnes
promises to give him a drum when he
turns three he calms down following this
the movie again fast forwards by three
years it is Oscar's third birthday and a
lot of guests and relatives have
gathered at his place as promised Agnes
gifts him with a toy drum making him
Happy Oscar parades around the house and
plays with it curiously completely
ignoring the celebrations going on
however when he notices the grown-ups
drinking alcohol he is disgusted so
Oscar decides to stay a child forever
that night he jumps from the staircase
and seriously injures himself when he's
taken to the hospital the doctors
diagnosed that he has ruptured certain
parts of the brain which control
physical growth now Oscar's wish is
granted he will remain a child forever a
few weeks later Oscar is discharged from
the hospital and he immediately starts
engaging with the tin drum he takes it
everywhere he goes whether it be at home
the market or even at school one day his
Fed Up dad tries to snatch the drum away
from him but Oscar unleashes a scream so
deadly that it smashes all the nearby
glass realizing that the kid has
superpowers the family lets him be what
what is going on in this movie three
more years pass and Oscar has turned six
he still hasn't grown by an inch and the
drum is always with him one day at
school a teacher tries to take it away
prompting Oscar to scream loudly this
not only hurts the other students but
also shatters the teacher's glasses at
home Agnes and Alfred have grown worried
due to their son's Antics on one hand he
doesn't grow physically and on the other
hand he is obsessed with the tin drum
they take him to different doctors
around the city but none of them can
come up with a cure once the parents
finally accept Oscar's fate they decide
to give him the best life they possibly
can so every Saturday Agnes takes him to
the city apparently to show him around
but in reality she leaves him in a toy
shop and goes to meet her lover yawn
they always make sure to have vigorous
intercourse one day Oscar catches his
mom in the ACT but he doesn't care at
all he simply wants to continue being a
kid and play with his tin drama six more
years pass by Oscar is now 12 but he
hasn't aged a day from his third
birthday one day his parents take him to
a circus where a bunch of dwarves are
performing seeing them Agnes and Alfred
wonder if their son is also a dwarf
after the show ends Oscar meets the
leader of the dwarves and demonstrates
his screaming abilities impressed the
leader invites him to join their group
and tour around the world however before
Oscar can reply his parents arrive and
take him away meanwhile the second world
war begins after Warsaw comes under
heavy attack attack from the Nazis
hundreds and thousands of Jews are
persecuted because of which a mass
emigration Begins the toy shop guy
Marcus also turns out to be a Jew and he
intends to move to London as soon as
possible he wants to take Agnes and
Oscar with him apparently because he has
developed a sense of affection towards
them unfortunately when Marcus tells
Agnes about the plan she polently
refuses and leaves the shop never to
come back again some more weeks pass and
the country of Poland starts slowly
plunging into chaos with the Soviets
joining in The Invasion the local people
become helpless the war affects Agnes
deeply and her son's continuous
Shenanigans doesn't Elevate her mood
either so one day she starts consuming a
lot of raw fish her family grows worried
because Agnes is allergic to fish they
try to stop her but to no avail
unfortunately the overconsumption of raw
fish takes her life as her digestive
system collapses due to food poisoning
talk about Carpe Diem at her funeral
many friends and relatives come to pay
their respects Marcus is also among them
but he is swiftly sent away way by the
Nazis due to his ethnicity however after
everyone leaves he returns and quietly
expresses his love for Agnes something
which he could never do when she was
alive unfortunately a few days later
Marcus's toy shop is burnt down by the
Nazis with his only source of livelihood
gone he plunges into depression and
ultimately commits the unthinkable when
little Oscar finds out about this he is
heartbroken not because he liked Marcus
but because his toy shop was the only
one in the city which repaired drums
since Oscar's old drum is now partially
damaged he goes to his second father Yan
for help the latter works at the local
post office where a lot of old drums
have been kept so Jan takes the little
boy there to get him a new one
unfortunately on that very day the Nazis
launched a surprise attack on the post
office eviscerating everything that
comes in their way several men are
killed on the spot and while Yan and the
others fight gallantly they are of no
match against the ruthless Nazis at last
Jan along with the remaining polish
survivors are taken outside and executed
one by one but luckily Marcus manages to
hide inside the post office long enough
until a Good Samaritan rescues him now
with his mother and second father both
dead Oscar starts living with Alfred
permanently one day the latter hires a
young maid named Maria Oscar is
immediately Smitten by her beauty and
always tries getting close to her hey
let me pull a grandpa and get in those
skirts but Maria simply treats him like
a child although they are of the exact
same age she is oblivious to it because
of Oscar's tiny body frame one morning
the little boy wakes up to an argument
happening in the living room when he
goes to inspect he shockingly sees his
father and Maria berating each other in
their scantily dressed attire they were
having an affair all along but Oscar had
no idea he is heartbroken to see the
love of his life being clapped by his
own father however things are not so
simple Maria genuinely loves Alfred and
wants to be with him but he simply sees
her as a commodity he doesn't want to
get married to her because of her age
that evening as Maria is crying alone in
the kitchen Oscar tries to comfort her
using his drum dad Candela but I can
paradiddle yeah but don't
however this only aggravates your mood
and she pushes him away calling him
names Maria soon realizes her mistake
and approaches the little boy to
apologize but instead he punches her in
the stomach nine months later we see
that Maria is heavily pregnant with
Alfred's child Oscar always stays by her
side but it is apparent that he is not
happy one day he quietly grabs a pair of
scissors and attempts to kill the unborn
baby but Maria stops him in the nick of
time with his plan foiled Oscar decides
to forget about her once and for all a
few weeks later Maria gives birth to a
healthy boy and seeing him Oscar changes
his attitude completely he starts caring
for the infant as if it is his own child
several months later as Oscars strolling
through the streets of Warsaw he comes
across a familiar friend it is none
other than the dwarf leader he met at
the circus years ago to Oscar's surprise
the dwarf now works for the Nazis as an
Entertainer He suggests that Oscar also
joined his group and travel to Paris
said that they can earn some money
together the little man is hesitant at
first saying he wants nothing to do with
the Nazis but when the dwarf reveals the
large amounts of cash they can earn he
agrees the decision turns out to be a
good one for Oscar as he lives some of
his happiest days in Nazi occupied Paris
along with a lavish lifestyle he also
makes some good friends who genuinely
understand his problems no one makes fun
of him for the fact that he carries a
tin drum wherever he goes moreover Oscar
also gets into a relationship for the
first time in his life she is one of the
entertainers named roswitha who is kind
and caring towards him unfortunately the
Happy Days don't last long as one day
some American soldiers raid the Nazi
base with heavy bombing Oscar and his
friends somehow managed to escape but
Ross with the is not so lucky she dies a
painful death right in front of Oscar's
eyes the incident traumatizes the little
man and unable to cope up with the
current situation he returns home Alfred
is ecstatic to have his son back but the
same cannot be said about Maria she
still despises him for the punch he
delivered to her stomach years ago
nonetheless Oscar is happy to be back
home when Maria's son turns three years
old he gifts him a tin drum just like
the one he got at the same age meanwhile
the war has escalated to the point where
walking on the streets has become
dangerous the Nazis are now executing
not only the Jews but also innocent
poles this terrifies Alfred because
although he is German his entire family
is Polish so to keep them safe Alfred
renovates his basement and hides
everyone there unfortunately One Day the
place is discovered by some Soviet
soldiers they interrogate the family one
by one and when Alfred is found to be
German he is executed on the spot the
following day a rich and influential
polish man named Marius takes over
Alfred's restaurant he also conducts the
recently deceased Chef's funeral citing
that he knows what it feels like to lose
a family member Marius explains that
just a few months ago his wife and
children passed away in an accident
Oscar is also present at the funeral and
this is when it finally Dawns on him
that he has become an orphan his mother
and both fathers have been killed so now
he wants to finally grow up and take
care of himself Oscar initiates the
first step towards being an adult by
throwing away his favorite Tin Drum he
painfully says goodbye as it was the
only thing that has stayed with him all
his life while his parents family
members and loved ones passed away one
by one the drum always remained by his
side just then his stepbrother strikes
him in the head with a rock knocking him
out everyone rushes to check on him and
when they see the blood gushing out of
his nostrils they become worried
fortunately there is a doctor among the
funeral attendees and he reports that
Oscar is not only fine but he will start
growing again the part of his brain that
is responsible for physical growth has
somehow healed after the impact hearing
this everyone becomes happy in the final
scene we are shown that the gruesome
Wars finally ended after the fall of
Berlin Poland is liberated after almost
six years of brutality however most of
the country has been torn apart so
hundreds of families are emigrating to
the West in search of a better life
among them are Maria and Oscar who
hurriedly get on a crowded train and
depart The City the movie ends as Oscar
notices his grandmother Anna staring at
him from the station he screams at the
top of his lungs to stop the train but
because he has started growing his
powers are gone Anna keeps on Staring at
him until the train goes out of sight
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching